moms all over the internet are sharing their 17 diapers
in reference to that mom who was struggling in postpartum
to take care of herself her toddler
her Newborn because her husband wasn't home
and ended up having kind of a messy house
and what they're sharing are the realities of postpartum depression
postpartum anxiety and postpartum psychosis
and I personally have found it incredibly cathartic
I have heard I haven't shared mine on here yet
but I've talked about it before on here
about my struggles with postpartum anxiety
because the people who are shaming the mom for having a dirty house
have no idea the depths of the struggle
of what it means to fight your own mind and fight demons within your own mind
they're out of your control
when I was in the depths of suffering from postpartum anxiety
I wasn't sure if I was going to make it
make it out you know
what you see on the news is always the worst case scenario
you know the mom who finally snaps
who either analyze herself or her children
but what you don't see often is the most commonplace scenarios
which is the suffering and silence that so many women do
you know a lot of moms are prepared to be sad
have the baby blues or whatever you wanna call it
but what I wasn't prepared for was panic attacks anxiety
intrusive thoughts
some of the like most horrific things rolling through my brain
as scenarios that I either were gonna cause
or had to find a way to save my babies from
and I just hope with the invention of social media
and how prevalent we are at sharing the realities of motherhood
that we are preparing the next generation of mothers to know the warning signs
and see the most common place struggles of postpartum depression
anxiety and psychosis
before they are drowning and before the worst case scenarios happen
because we all know it's gonna be up to us as a community and us as individuals
to prepare other women
and not the systems that we have in place to actually support women
but I know for me
it has been incredibly healing to see these being shared online
so maybe I'll share mine soon
or maybe this is me sharing my 17 diapers